these policemen make no attempt to hide
their contempt for Russia
at the entrance to isium they celebrate
the city's return to Ukrainian control
even the interior Minister shows up
excuse
we met in um
do you mind how are you feeling you're
standing here isium the entrance to ISM
you've just been visiting how are you
feeling
happy just now
but from Another Side here I am not
upset because many our Ukrainian
citizens I mean civilians we found here
and they did by Russians and its problem
for us also
it's not hard to see why
that's the remnants of a cluster bomb in
the city center
the scale of the suffering here is only
starting to emerge as police return to
the streets now Russia's occupation has
ended
[Music]
[Music]
and are you able to say how they died
yet or do you just not know
um
if you're a police chief yes you're an
investigator but you are also a human
as a as a human how did you feel lemons
[Music]
we saw the top investigator at work last
weekend his team recovered the remains
of two men from a garden in this tiny
village they'd been shot dead
more than 20 bodies have already been
retrieved across newly liberated parts
of kharkiv region
it's a hugely difficult task but police
are determined to secure Justice
and to help their people move on
Deborah Haynes Sky News kharkiv